la république en marche parti
présidentiel soutient la liste
renaissance l'arrêt modem arrive en tête
ici en martinique lors des dernières
européennes partie on va dire un peu
scotché en termes d'implantations dans
notre île bonjour lydia beaulieu
monsieur kalt auditeurs la référente
dans marche depuis début mai première
question que tout le monde se pose
comment expliquer votre faible
implantation en martinique faible
implantation je suis pas d'accord avec
l'étincelant structuration si vous
préférez c'est peut-être plus une faible
visibilité parce que nous avons quand
même plusieurs comités locaux nous avons
des adhérents et alors il est vrai que
nous avons souffert sur les deux
derniers moins d'une vacance de référent
mais non mon papa de ce faible
implantation plutôt un souci de
visibilité tout le monde et marcheurs
tout le monde veut marche en tête il ya
un organigramme a crié un comité de
pilotage conseil politique a reconstitué
alors oui oui effectivement comme je
vous ai expliqué laraque ans de 2 mois
ça ça ça remet en question un certain
nombre de choses qui avait été mise en
place
quoi par exemple belle l'organisation
autour de du référent fin de la
référente en l'occurrence donc il faut
reconstruire
effectivement l'équipe de direction et
puis comme je disais un quand on est
entre guillemets sans tête pendant si
longtemps
sadi mobilise donc il va falloir aussi
redynamiser l'on vous voulez tenir
compte uniquement de ces deux mois qui
viennent de se passer et tout ce qui
s'est passé avant vous en faites croire
tout ce qui s'est passé avant ces
manuels macro élus en 2017 pendant deux
ans votre parti a fait quoi vous étiez
de la campagne pour la présidentielle a
fait nous nous avons nous avons fait des
démarches nous avons fait la marche du
monde
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de la
population des élus aussi donc c'est un
travail qui est capitalisée oui et puis
cohabiter politique qui a volé en éclats
que deviennent ces mères qui sont qui
était à ce comité politique
alors je vais je vais les recontacter
pour le moment je n'ai pu que les
invités
un autre notre meeting durant la
campagne faut aller jusqu à profit le
meur du lourd j'ai contacté monsieur
pamphilj marche mais je sais je dois les
contacter et en nouvelles références je
rappelle que j'ai été nommé le 7 mars et
ça fait moins d'un mois
j'ai estimé que c'est le père du
commerce vous l'avez déjà entendu sur
les ondes
gelly entendu et je n'ai pas entendu
dire qu'il ne souhaitait plus être
marcheurs donc je fais la démarche de le
contacter alors à ce moment-là je
disposais de de peu d'outils donc j'ai
fait un petit peu rapidement mais j'ai
bien l'intention de renouer le dialogue
ne serait ce que pour clarifier la
situation est pire que séraphin qui est
devenu marcheurs également
officiellement il ya peu premiers mois
oui c'est bien nous expliquer pourquoi
il a tardé à prendre sa carte lui
faudrait lui poser la question nous
poserons la question
vers 4h montplaisir arrivera font
plaisir j repris contact aussi par enfin
j'ai les invités voilà comment dirais-je
meeting est pareil je vais je vais me
rapprocher de lui au cours de ce meeting
ya quand même pas mal de tête qu'on
connaissait ici en martinique des
marcheurs de la première heure 1 chantal
mignon oui daniel robin oui battu gamma
oui daniel chomette lordinot la liste
est longue
oui oui mais bon ce sont des personnes
qui étaient là qui étaient plus ou moins
été remerciés qui sont pas alors je
rappelle continue à graviter autour je
rappelle qu'une autre personnalité sur
la liste renaissance c'était une liste
de rassemblement
l'élection qui est en jeu si tu es les
élections européennes c'est une élection
d'importance et dans ce genre de
situation il faut un rassemblement le
plus large possible parce que c'est un
enjeu qui dépasse des enjeux strictement
partisan l'europe c'est important et
c'est important pour nous aussi
et quand je dis nous je parle de la
martinique le 10 à beaulieu la liste
renaissance et arrive en tête en
martinique devant le rassemblement
national contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé en guyane en guadeloupe à saint
pierre et miquelon
mais la liste renaissance et arrive en
tête avec
locale avec max orville qui avait déjà
dit sur nos antennes bien que la
république en marche et pas tellement ce
culture en martinique
il fallait sous-entendre fallait
comprendre il fallait lire entre les
lignes pour dire que finalement le
véritable patron peut-être de cette
liste renaissance c'est lui vous avez
composé comme avec lui on a travaillé en
très bonne collaboration
encore une fois je c'était une liste de
rassemblement c'est pas l'idée n'est pas
de se focaliser sur des personnes l'idée
était de 2-2 faire en sorte que notre
liste arrive en tête en martinique
ben ça s'est passé et bach sorvino a
décrété sur cette antenne que son
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner ce que
le vôtre sont également pas spécialement
je suis nommé depuis il va falloir
davantage quoi par rapport à moi
peut-être commercial pour lui demander
des conseils
comment faire si orville et et futurs
députés européens il me semble légitime
que son téléphone sonne moi j'ai un
travail à faire au sein de notre
mouvement je vous ai dit il faut
redynamiser
je veux rencontrer les adhérents je n'ai
pas eu le temps de le faire puisque j'ai
eu à peine nommé il a fallu que je me
concentre sur la campagne sur la
réception aussi de guy l'avocat qui
était colistier de la république en
marche la lah et puis membre du bureau
exécutif 7,1 pour une visite
d'importance donc on s'est focalisé sur
sûr sur cette visite sur le meeting qui
est allé deux temps forts pour nous et
maintenant je vais pouvoir enfin me
consacrer un autre mouvement
max orville vous donnera quelques
conseils des conseils acquérir pour
votre structuration pour la
structuration de renaissance en
martinique alors que les municipales
vont arriver bientôt je ne poserai la
question de savoir si ce sera
renaissance ce sera le modem de côté la
république en marche de l'autre on envie
de comprendre comment les choses vont se
passer quelle sera votre agenda par
exemple de rencontre avec vos
sympathisants vos supporters pour leur
candidat alors pour répondre à la
première question
monsieur en ville il est il doit gérer
son parti le modem à moi de gérer la
république en marche des conseils je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas nous nous
allons échanger
nous sommes le modem et la république en
marche sont des alliés historiques
donc voilà maintenant libre à moi de
m'organiser
voilà on a un agenda l'agenda il n'est
pas encore défini par rapport aux
bénéfices municipal on a une commission
d'investiture qui a été créée je crois
hier donc c'est dans le cadre de cette
commission qu'on va discuter
effectivement de du futur agenda des
municipales les diabolos vous êtes
originaire de la commune de saint joseph
ont favorisé des rares auteurs
est ce que cette commune pourrait vous
intéresser en tant que municipal
je n'exclus rien je n'exclus rien encore
une fois je vous ai dit la commission
vient d'être créée donc nous allons être
sollicité par cette commission pour
savoir quelle décision prendre sur les
municipales ça risque de se bousculer à
saint joseph
il y à une députée manuela qui est
clairement désir qui est assise à
l'assemblée nationale dans l'opposition
emmanuel macron équipe où les
européennes a apporté son soutien à la
liste renaissance donc candidate
potentielle aux municipales il ya
également laurence l'horizon qui était
candidate à la candidature pour le poste
de référence de référence en marche ça
c'est beaucoup de monde ça fait du monde
mais bon c'est souvent lesquin sur les
municipales vous entendez bien avec
madame minc et clermont désiré amon
amusant j'ai j'ai eu l'occasion
effectivement 2
d'échangés avec la députée six mois
c'est le cas avec madame louise o mais
j'ai les marcheuses donc je vais je
n'ose pareil je vous ai dit et il me
faut rencontrer les adhérents tous les
adhérents
si je me rappelle bien lorsque nous
recevions les responsables et premier
responsable dans marche en martinique il
semblait mettre l'accent sur une quelque
chose de fondamental pour l'implantation
de votre parti politique
il aurait fallu faire le nettoyage le
ménage ne pas être très vigilant sur des
personnes qu'ils chercheraient à adhérer
à en marché ce que vous restez dans
cette logique là éviter la liste
l'adhésion est libre donc on va pas être
vigilant sur les adhésions
on ne va pas enfin on peut pas décider à
la place des gens s'ils sont si l'on
cherche une éventuelle de structures ou
là nous sommes maintenant moi je suis
convaincu que la meilleure façon de
fonctionner c'est de ces le dialogue
donc on ne peut pas s'interdire de
discuter avec qui que ce soit ensuite
après discussion les choses sont
beaucoup plus claires on est d'accord où
on n'est pas d'accord mais je ne ferme
la porte à personne
le profil type selon vos de la personne
qui pourrait avoir l'investiture dans
marche pour les prochaines municipales
ce serait quoi
le profil type quelqu'un qui déjà
partage les valeurs du mouvement
ensuite qui apporte un projet crédible
pour la municipalité
je crois que ce sont les deux principaux
atouts
les avis des experts en ce genre de
choses en ayant eu toutes les couleurs
politiques qui existent sur l'échiquier
politique
sortie reprocher c'est très facile et
oui oui oui c'est sûr c'est le rêve
alors c'est très vite à conviction ont
grandi il faut il faut être convaincant
au niveau aussi des administrés après
tout c'est eux qui choisissent donc si
on offre un projet qui n'est pas en
phase avec ce qu'attendent la population
ça ne fonctionnera pas
après les municipales il y aura la ctm
sans risque ce sera un enjeu majeur pour
vous bien sûr
on est un jeune mouvement on a encore
participé à l'élection vous êtes le
parti présidentiel
c'est un jeune mouvement que ça fait
deux ans que le parti existe donc les
élections à la fois municipal est à la
fois territoriale départementale
régionale et puis la collectivité en ce
qui nous concerne sont des enjeux
majeurs pour le mouvement ono plan
national et ça va arriver effectivement
ce déclic est déclinée pardon au plan
local
en ce qui nous concerne pour la setil
une dernière question concernant le
rassemblement national qui a fait de
très bons scores quand même ici en
martinique lors des dernières
européennes
il y aura une stratégie particulière à
mettre sur pied pour a bien contré 7,7
monter la meilleure stratégie c'est la
proximité et la pédagogie je crois qu il
nous faut tous nous mobiliser quand j'ai
dit tout ce je parle de tous les élus
c'est un combat qui est important
le rassemblement national ne peut pas
continuer à être en tête dans tous les
outre-mer
je suis je me félicite que simpson ça
n'ait pas été le cas en martinique
mais le combat c'est une bataille de
gagnée la guerre continue merci lydia
beaulieu d'avoir été ce matin dans son
caddie on rappelle que vous êtes la
référence en marche depuis un mois merci
d'avoir à se battre avec nous dans son
caddie bonne journée
[Musique]
beaucoup